[Music]
today we're going to build a cloud
function that's capable of resizing an
image into multiple thumbnails after its
initially uploaded this is one of the
most commonly needed features for a
cloud storage bucket but doing it
requires some pretty advanced no js'
code in today's video we'll build this
cloud function from scratch and do
everything we can to optimize
performance for the fastest possible
execution if you're new the channel like
and subscribe and if you want to get
really good at cloud functions consider
enrolling in my cloud functions master
course which was just released yesterday
the of course is free if you're already
a pro member but if not I'll go ahead
and leave a discount code in the video
description as well to get started I am
assuming that you have the firebase
command line tools installed then we can
run firebase and net functions in any
existing project I'm going to select
typescript here but you could also
select JavaScript but I would recommend
that you use the new node js8 runtime
because we'll be using a lot of
async/await syntax here and that's not
available in a default node 6 runtime
once that's done we can see the end of
the functions directory and then we have
a couple of dependencies to install here
the cloud functions environment by
default doesn't have tools set up for
you to download files from a storage
bucket but we can install the Google
Cloud Storage nodejs client to take care
of that for us when a storage cloud
function is triggered it doesn't give
you access directly to the file but
instead it just gives you some
information about the file that was
uploaded so we'll need the Google Cloud
Storage library to actually download it
and resize the image and then re-upload
those back to the bucket we're also
going to install a library called sharp
because it's four to five times faster
than the image magic library that's
installed in the cloud functions
environment and if you've ever used
image magic in a cloud function before
you'll know that it's pretty cumbersome
sharp is just way more
developer-friendly it's promise based
and we'll be able to do all of our
resizing with a single line of code
the last dependency I'll install is node
file system extra this is a promise
based version of the node file system
which tends to be much more easy to work
with in a cloud functions environment
let's go ahead and install that with NPM
then we'll have everything in place
we need to work with files in a
developer friendly way the goal of this
function is to listen for a file upload
to be finalized when that happens it
will take the source file resize it into
multiple different sizes that you can
specify and then re-upload them into
that same directory in the bucket one
thing that's really important to keep in
mind here is that when you have a
storage cloud function that gets
triggered on finalize that will get
triggered for every single file that
gets uploaded to this bucket including
the thumbnails that we upload from the
function itself that's really important
because we need to give our code a
certain exit point to know when to not
upload a file because otherwise we'll
end up in an infinite loop if you create
an infinite loop your bucket will end up
with thousands of new files uploaded to
it and it won't stop uploading until it
reaches the quota limits and if you
don't catch it early you might rack up
some unnecessary charges on your
firebase bill now we'll go ahead and
jump into the code and just to warn you
the most complicated thing about this
function is keeping track of the
different file paths between the local
functions file system and the storage
bucket
first we'll instantiate the storage
client which we'll use to download and
upload files then every cloud function
has a temporary directory that you can
write files to the way you access it is
with this temp dir method from node and
then we'll also import a couple of
helpers from node join allows us to join
paths together and directory name allows
us to get the directory from a file name
and lastly we'll bring in sharp and FS
extra that we installed earlier we can
give the cloud function a name of
generate thumbs and we'll have it run on
the on finalize event on the storage
bucket which just means that a file was
fully uploaded somewhere in the bucket
we'll be awaiting a whole bunch of
different promises in this function so
we'll make the callback on the function
itself an async function we need to tell
the Cloud Storage client which bucket to
use to upload and download files which
we can just get from the object that
triggered this function then we have a
handful of different variables that we
need to define here just to keep track
of the paths in the storage bucket and
in the local system we can get the full
path to the file in the bucket by
calling object name
then we'll make a reference to that file
name as well and we'll also want to make
reference to the directory that this
file came from because that's eventually
where we're going to upload our
thumbnails to now we need to download
the source file to a working directory
and then we'll also need to save our
thumbnails in a working directory
temporarily as well so what I'm going to
do is create a new directory in a
temporary directory called thumbs
because we'll eventually want to delete
this once we exit the function just to
clean everything up and lastly I'll
define a path for where we're going to
download the source image which I'll
just call source dot PNG at this point
we need to set up our break point to
avoid causing an infinite loop the
concept is exactly the same as a
recursive function and programming
fundamentals we want to exit from this
function early if it's been triggered by
an image that's already been resized and
we'll figure that out by using this
thumb at keyword if that string is
present in the file name then we just
want to exit because we know that it's
already been resized and at this point
we can also check if the content type is
not an image in that case we'll also
want to exit early you can exit from a
function by just returning false and
that will prevent the execution of any
code that comes after it now that we
have the initial setup done we just have
a series of steps to go through that are
pretty straightforward if you look at
them step by step the first one is we
need to make sure that our working
directory exists otherwise we'll get an
error if we try to use it and we can do
that with FS ensure directory with our
directory path now that we know the
directory exists we'll go ahead and
download the source file to that working
directory which we'll do with the GCSE
library we can await the bucket file to
be downloaded to the path that we
defined in that working directory after
the file is downloaded the third step is
to resize it to the thumbnail sizes that
we want and then we'll want to set up an
array of promises that represent the
upload operations for each one of those
thumbnails there are different ways you
can do this but what I'm going to do is
set up an array of different thumbnail
sizes then I'll map that array to an
array of promises where each promise is
an upload operation back to the bucket
we can run those promises concurrently
which should improve
performance especially if you have a lot
of different thumbnail sizes each
thumbnail will have that thumb at
keyword followed by its size and in the
original file name then will define the
full path to the working directory where
we'll save that file when you call nap
on an array it's just looping over its
values so what we'll do here is await
the Sharpe library to resize the image
and save it to the local file system
which we do by just passing it the
original source image call resize with
the size we want it to be and you can
also call a whole bunch of different
other methods here in sharp resizing
like this we'll crop the image from the
center and size it to these dimensions
then we say to file with the thumbnail
path and then the last thing we'll do in
this map operation is return the bucket
upload with this newly saved file then
we'll set the destination to the
original files destination with this new
file name so that gives us an array of
promises now the only thing we have to
do is run them which we can do by saying
a weight promise all with these upload
promises that will run the uploads
concurrently and then once that's
complete the last step is to just delete
these files from the file system since
they're no longer needed
so as the fifth and final step we'll go
ahead and return from the function with
FS removed the working directory now
let's go ahead and deploy the function
so we can test it out now any files that
get uploaded to storage will
automatically get a series of thumbnails
generated for them and the performance
should be pretty solid in most cases
I've seen latency of about one or two
seconds but performance really depends
on the size of the file that was
uploaded and also the number of
thumbnails that you're generating I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and don't forget to check out
the cloud functions master course I'd
love to get your feedback and hear
additional cloud functions topics that
you'd like to see covered in the future
thanks for watching and I'll talk to you
soon